there we go so there's some people here
that weren't at the last meeting so I'm
going to just ask we go around again and
introduce ourselves tell us who we who
you represent um and uh and go from
there so we'll start over here with
representa uh The Honorable Pat bramy
thank you P bramy from stratum uh former
State Rep for six
terms uh I was on Ways and Means all
that time very familiar with this the
issue of charitable gaming and uh thank
you yeah Norman Roberge again conquered
Lions Club representing the charitable
gaming sponsors if you want
activities good morning everyone Charlie
McIntyre I'm the director of H Lottery
uh Senator L representing District py in
Manchester I'm fairly familiar with
hiire representative Joe Sweeney from
Salem I'm new to the committee so it's
exciting to be here with all of you to
to work on our gaming laws and study the
recent changes to it as I said represent
Salem which is a town with a proud
history of supporting gaming uh in our
in our sweep stakes and lottery so
excited to be here thank
you I'm I'm representative dick Ames I'm
uh from Jeffrey in my 11th year and in
the house and um I uh chaired an earlier
Commission on uh on gaming way back
whenever eight years ago nine years 10
years ago maybe uh that's it thank
you good morning representative Fred
ducet uh familiar theme will be heard
here all also serving out of Salem and
in my fifth ter and I also serve on ways
and
means
great and I'm Senator Tim Lang I am a
four-term legislator serving three terms
in the house I served all three terms I
was on the Ways and Means Committee as
well as I'm currently the chair of the
Ways and Means Committee um for the
Senate uh and obviously having seven
years on ways and means I pretty pretty
familiar with the charitable gaming laws
so that being said we're going to move
on to electing a new chair um this is an
organizational meeting um to reform and
then upon electing a chair um we'll have
a presentation from Lottery one thing
when we get to the presentation I'm
hoping we'll do is we'll hold all
questions while Charlie gets through his
entire presentation and then ask
questions so we don't interrupt them
because we'll probably find it on a
later slide so
representative bomy yes uh thank you
Senator Lang um are you we can approve
the minutes first uh well I was going to
have the chair elected but I can do that
so there's minutes presented for August
14th um I'd entertain a motion the
minutes well the reason I said that I'm
missing from the minutes as being
present thank you so so we get a motion
then we can amend them so okay you move
move to adop adopt the minutes is there
a second to adopting the minutes second
it's been moved in second to adopt the
minutes it sounds like we have at least
one edit and that is member appointed by
the
governor I don't fit into any of these
other categories yep yep so public
member um will add um to the minutes the
present any other edits or updates to
the
minutes seeing on all those in favor say
I I all those opposed say nay yeah I
have it minutes are adopted um senator
sort of point of a question
um last time we didn't really sort of
have a official minutes keeper and
somebody had to help the committee um I
had spoken last time about bringing some
of the folks I work with to help and I
brought somebody I don't know don't know
if you've arranged for somebody to sort
of act as an assistant or I I I brought
somebody who works with me to do that if
you so I think the plan was for your
person to do it uh John represented
janigian is our official clerk okay so
once the minutes are taken if you can
forward on to him and then he'll
overview them and then the commit she's
with me here I don't know if you want to
sit the table is an open yeah she can
sit at the end of the table that'd be
great so it's easier for her to take
notes
okay thank you yeah and Li um she's on
her way up probably wondering why I
called up like this
but this is the one who get who gets the
privilege or sad sad event to work with
me every day Kelly procket
so is it Kelly thank you Kelly um so so
next up is election of chair um so I'll
open the floor for nominations Senator
dandro thank you Mr I nominate Pat Abby
for chair of the commission and very
briefly I Ser let hold on second let's
get a second and then you can speak to
the nomination it's been moved by
Senator delandro seconded by
representative duet for Pat bramy you
want to speak to your nomination very
thank you Mr chair uh I've known Pat Bry
for a number of years and know of his
interest in this subject matter and the
amount of time and effort that he has
spent uh in this in this Arena I know
I've been around this for the last 25
years and I uh he's been a good
colleague I think knows knows uh the
business knows what what needs to be
looked at and I think that could bring
us a very objective opinion as to what
the what the B what the main concerns
are of the populace how to address those
concerns and and how to address the
charges that have been stated under the
missions of the commission uh so with
that I uh enthusiastically support um P
brby for chairman thank you for further
seea
what you hold on let me see if I get a
second for that before you get into it I
apologize seconding by uh representative
nomination
operators everybody I we need a lot more
information
thank you any further
discussion seeing none will jump to the
back thank
now I'll vote for myself as well so it's
7 to5 uh Pat you're going to be the
shair so again take over the meeting
meting
start
I think that we need to we need to
address all of those things um when I
chair I chaired the marijuana commission
years ago um we took a blank sheet of
paper and we said okay if we were to do
legalization of marijuana what should it
look like I think that's what this
commission should be doing it's a new
world we should be looking at Char
gaming I think we all support charal
gaming here we want to see charal gaming
uh but we want to make sure that with
the new landscape that the way we
approach it is what we want as this
group and the final report of this will
be a guide hopefully we create a guide
for the legislature going forward as to
what we want charitable gaming to look
like so this is very important
commission uh again we've grown up from
a mom and pop operations to Big Time
Casino companies coming in so it's it's
just a moment in time that we need to
pause and we need to address all the
issues and I do have a handout I'll give
out later about that so with that um
Charlie you're
up so if you look at your minutes
we
theed right obviously we're going to
make sure we meet the five Charters um I
think there's a lot of
other issues that are going to
arise um and it's up to the group if we
think we're straying from the task then
we won't go there but I know in the
marijuana commission we went were let us
um because it was an important issue and
we came up with 54 recommendations that
were outside the bounds of that so if
you want to stay with these five things
fine some some of my issues may fall
Within These five or six whatever it is
five um but yeah
no thank you Mr CH I I think all of us
know that charitable gabing is here to
stay I don't think there's any question
about that it's how charitable gaming is
run is charitable gaming fulfilling the
rationale for charitable gaming are all
of the players playing under the same
rules and are those rules being applied
uniformly across the board and indeed
is the
security that we talk about being being
necessary for this to work is that in
place and is that functioning is that
functioning charitable charitable Gabby
has
become a huge entity in in in our state
I think we have operating at the present
time at least 12 casinos at least 12 and
I don't know how many others around
under uh under preparation for for
opening at at the present time uh there
was a time when proliferation was a real
concern of the people of the State of
New Hampshire and a real concern of the
legislature and obviously that's not a
concern anymore and as a result of that
I think uh the landscape has changed and
as legislators it's our job to make sure
that the landscape is the landscape that
we organized we brought forward and we
legislated and if that's not if that's
not the case then things have to be done
to correct that I served on the
commission uh a number a number of years
ago and we did annunciate a number of
things that had to be taken care of I
think some of those have been but some
of those have not so those are the
things that we have to I think we have
responsibility that's an awesome resp
gaming gaming is on television more than
the damn
news every I mean they're beating
prescriptions I'd say you get your
prescriptions at
DraftKings that's the place to go there
are more ads for gaming on television
than anything else to me it's it's
unbelievable so these these are things
that have happened over the last couple
of years that that really uh are are
important very important uh and what
what about the habitual
Gibler how what what place is that in
our society and where and where's that I
guess I've spoken too long but thank you
comments thank you um yes I I agree with
uh um the sentiment that we need to look
broadly and I think that's uh that that
need is you look at these five bullet
points it becomes immediately evident
whether the state should limit the
number of charitable gaming
locations uh well how do you answer that
question you need to dive deeply into uh
what the demand is what the other states
have done in terms of limiting or not
limiting uh charal gaming sites and uh
and why they've done that and uh how
that affects revenue and another one is
whether more HHR licens would increase
reduce revenues to Charities again you
got to dive deeply to figure that one
out and uh so I I think we need to look
broadly in order to answer these
questions and I concur with Senator
delandro that uh this is a time where
it's very important to do so it's uh New
Hampshire is moving on uh on the
gambling issue and we need to make sure
it's moving in a good direction okay
thank you any other comments okay
Charlie you're up do you want to you
want to go up here so we can all
okay just have your other people
yeah
thank
you
if if you would be so kind to not tell
admin services that I use color Inc I'd
appreciate
it um good morning everyone once again
Charlie McIntyre director of Hampshire
Lottery with me is Valerie King who's
head of our licensing and John con who
is the Lottery's Chief compliance
officer uh and they do this a lot more
than I do so I'll look look to them to
answer questions and go through this as
you go through this presentation but
certainly we'll start with the basics I
imagine this will be the first of many
times that I or my colleagues will be
sitting here asking questions and and
and the like so I'll you know we'll
start at the beginning and work our way
forward obviously the Charities derive
significant revenue from the operation
of charitable gambling one area we do
not regulate which has often come under
um question is
Raffles we have nothing to do with
Raffles so the if you have a raffle and
city or town you seek permission from
that city or town usually the police
department um permits you for a raffle
held in that town or sometimes you don't
seek PR it and we don't know about it so
otherwise there are four areas
essentially of trable gambling that we
regulate Bingo uh Lucky Seven which are
obviously I think everyone knows what
Bingo is I certainly grew up helping
Bingo when a St ANS and quiny um Lucky
Seven are called pull tabs other names
are also called break open or seal cards
these are cards you can buy that you
break open and if you match you win um
they are the comparator or the companion
really to bingo games you have to bingo
license to sell Lucky s tickets and they
are the profit Center for most Charities
that do run bingo bingo is actually lost
leader but Lucky 7 tickets make money a
number of years ago our predecessor
agency not ours but the predecessor
agency racing and triable gambling
approved machines what year was that 15
2015 2015 and shortly after that we were
they were merged with us and became one
agency essentially all gambling in the
state in the Lottery
Commission third area is games of chance
obviously which are Casino style games
and historic horse racing is the fourth
and we'll go through them one at the
time Val you want to SC Bingo want me
um so just to give you an overview of
bingo it's it's your traditional Bingo
we don't do electronic Bingo it's it's
all your traditional callers calling
numbers at the um local Bingo halls um
they're they're generally held at
commercial bingo halls but they can also
be held at um locations owned by a
charity like a a basement of a church or
whatever um they must be operated by the
members of the
organization they can have assistance
from licensed gaming Consultants but the
charity is the one in charge and
supposed to be operating the the
games um the charitable organization
retains all of the revenue that they
generate with the exception of a 7% um
fee on carry over coverall and winner
take all games which the state
collects
um as as Charlie mentioned Bingo itself
is a loss leader which is why they often
sell Lucky Seven tickets at their bingo
events because that's really where the
money is made and they have different
fun little games like Charlie mentioned
seal cards that help uh generate most of
their
revenue and that's the the basics of
bingo okay uh second obviously Lucky
Seven and Lucky Seven as it described is
sold in two ways one is through paper an
actual physical ticket that is printed
and sold in deal sizes and the second is
through a machine and is similarly sold
in a deal but is rendered
electronically and printed on paper but
is not the primary way the W the person
finds out if they want or not
um
The Lucky Seven tickets have a payout
similar to what a scratch ticket would
in terms of priz to the player
um the state receives a deal fee of $15
per deal of $3600 tickets 3600 tickets
as you can imagine this is not
particularly what's our revenue from
Lucky
7 uh for deal for year for year I think
it's like two two two two million about
two million about two million a year for
for Lucky 7 both um physical as well as
mechanical
machines yeah just interjected one thing
I just want fire five
the Lucky Sevens used to be uh only able
to be sold in conjunction with bingo
games but um the legislature did make a
change I believe two years ago to allow
at games of chance facilities um so
there are a few games of chance
facilities that have electronic Lucky 7
um those are generally the facilities
that do not have uh historic horse
racing um and so obviously as historic
hor racing has come on it's replaced a
lot of that electronic Lucky 7 um
uh business um but it is still um
possible and it does happen that Lucky
Seven sales do take place at games and
license want you walk through games a
chance
do
chance uh so uh Tim do you the emails of
commission yeah so uh you should be
copying on a couple emails that have
everybody in but I'll make make sure you
get them okay because I was going to
pass something around but no I'll make
sure you get Mr chairman I know Kelly
right so with with games of chance uh as
mentioned earlier those are your Casino
tile games your black Blackjack your
poker your roulette um they're
technically they can be operated by a
charity but it's really not feasible so
they're operated at games of chance
calls basically your casinos we have
approximately 14 14 14 licensed game
rooms at this time
um each charity in order to operate
games of chance at at one of these uh
facilities you have to have a charity
host charity and each charity gets 10
game dates per year um at yeah up to 10
games game dates per year the revenue
that the um the room earns on that game
night the charity gets 35% and the game
operator retains 65% however the game
operator can also charge rent um on top
and and so that reduces the Chari
portion
um
[Music]
right so so the the state does take uh
10% of the it's 10% of house winnings is
what the state tax is unless it's a
tournament which is 3% of the money put
tournament and that's the last bullet
so and S of lastly and the certainly one
of the areas that's been focused for the
last few months uh historic horse racing
which was approved during the last
legislative session um it is the
replay
in of priorly run horse races
randomized um for display with an
entertaining display um for a
player um these exist I think in five
states I think it's five states around
the us none near us the closest I think
is Virginia um Iowa Arkansas has it too
um
and right now I think within the state
there are 1500
1500 1,00 1500 machines in the state and
so one of the what was that number again
I think it's the, 1400 150000 I can get
you the exact number but it changes
daily as you could imagine some come
offline some go online some get repaired
some get moved but how many how many
facilities actually have them so at this
point it's yeah it's 10 facilities have
them now and that number is growing but
to put it in context if I could because
there's a certainly a perception when
you're talking 12 15 16 um Twin Rivers
has 3,500 machines in it so to put it in
context in terms of size it's still a
fraction of as big as the one in Rhode
Island at Twin Rivers so it's
not there aren't 14 siiz Twin Rivers
facilities in the state there are or 10
there are are all told they don't equal
half of what Twin Rivers has in terms of
gaming machines I'm going to call them
gaming machines people call them what
they want but the legislature called
them historic hor racing machines I
think we can all agree they are gaming
machines by the broad definition that
our industry uses them um and I don't
like the other words that we we call
them so
um and so it's a maximum of 12% of the
handle is taken out I think right now
it's running about 10 yeah it's slightly
10 yeah
yeah exact but up 10% so every dollar
put in 90 cents is coming back out as
winnings to the player the remaining 10
cents is left over um there's a unit of
measure in our business called win per
unit per day it's how much is left in in
the tail after a player played a bunch
one lost one lost one one lost lost um
and of that dollar that's in the tails
for example 75 cents goes to the
operator uh 16.2
5 sense goes to the Lottery Commission
and 8.75 is shared between the two
Charities that are hosting the events at
that facility that
night oh sorry I just of um because I I
led my boss astray uh so I just checked
the last time we did a census at the end
of August it was 1,600 machines um
that's grown uh since then um as Charlie
said that will change literally day to
day certainly week to week week and so
we do track that every month or so so at
this point it's probably as I said last
census was 1618 machines um that'll
probably be closer to 1,800 the next
time we do that sorry than
um one of the rules that we promulgated
through jail car approval is that HHR
Revenue cannot exceed by more than 6.33
times uh table Revenue the games of
chance Revenue that's for a very
specific reason is because on games of
chance Revenue the charity receives 35
cents in the Dollar on a store horse
racing Revenue they receive
eight machines are far easier to run and
manage they are far easier and cheaper
to regulate they are cheaper to deal
with and so I we didn't want a situation
where the Charities which is the reason
we're doing this
are are held to a det ment because it's
easier to have machines that it is to
have dealers at tables and surveillance
cameras and Pit Bosses and change of
shifts and all that and so we want to
make sure that in any end that no the
Charities would not lose out on this
process that um all the table games
would go away and there' be nothing but
machines and buildings and the like so
um those places have certain names none
of which are appealing so that's the
reason for that rule
um
and if they do exceeded that number then
half of the HHR Revenue goes to the
Charities at night it's not a
disincentive it's not a punishment it's
just meant that you probably should have
spent more time promoting charitable
gambling versus you know your profit
line um and obviously the breakage from
that is earmark for problem gambling
Services um one of the things I will be
seeking this legislative session is a
fix to that last year
the legislature budgeted
$150,000 for problem gambling Services
breakage exceeded that by
$38,000 right now our CFO is having
conceptions because he has an extra
$38,000 it doesn't know what to do with
it's meant to go for problem gambling
services but it can't because it's only
budgeted $150,000 and we have 188,000 to
send there so it'll be a request next
session to fix that
part
um
we go through license requirements you
sure um so the licensing requirements on
slide seven that's specific to games of
chance and HHR only um in order to have
HHR you have to be a game operator
employer so the license requirements are
number one for the game operator
employer itself which is the game room
um the operator of the games
um these can be either and the these are
generally the entities um and so we
review The Entity itself and anyone that
they rely on financially for their
support the the next group is going to
be your primary and secondary game
operators and those requirements are
basically that they have to be 18 years
or older and they can't have a criminal
background that um either a felon or
misdemeanor that involves um deceit or
theft and then you have your charitable
organizations um they just have to show
eligibility to be defined as a terrible
organization under the statute which is
you have to be registered with Secretary
of State for at least one year you have
to be registered with charitable trust
if required by law and um what's the
other one oh and you have to have IRS
tax exemption and
be not be on their Auto revocation list
you want me to go to the next sure Mr Mo
so just to go go through um in order to
be a goe you have to have a suitability
determination and so basically we start
by um the the legislature gave us the
authority to perform that work and then
we send it to the AG's office for review
and their um overall approval
approval so we begin by um we have the
applicants they have to fill out a
multi-jurisdictional uh form that gives
us all their data and statistics and and
and things that we need to look at they
have to undergo a criminal history check
through the state police
their we do a financial review oh thank
you um a financial review of all their
financial statements um any judgments or
petitions that are against them in the
court and then we review any deny
denials or revocations they've had here
or in any other state regarding
gaming let me jump in so so certainly
that effort is compiled it takes many
days as you could imagine to compile
that data there's a usually a back and
forth between our staff as well as the
operator who's applying for the license
um and that takes in the process under
the law has to happen within 90 days for
HHR and we usually we usually take 45
days and the Attorney General usually
takes 45 days at that time so
uh it's an exhaustive process obviously
you're we're trying to dissuade or
dissuade wrong word stop folks from who
would not be eligible to have a gaming
license in any other state from having a
gaming license in this state
um and obviously after that we submit
our findings recommendations to the
attorney general for his
review once we get an approval from the
AG's office we also need to make sure
that the room itself is ready to operate
so we'll do a site visit we um review
all the internal control controls um all
of their documentation that they use in
the game room and we actually perform a
site visit we review their surveillance
um their how they do their their um cash
drops and whatnot if they're all ready
license on the next slide is merely just
a sort of a graph to show you the flow
revenue and describing how um it's
essentially the split between the
operator and the remainder to the state
Charities and the next slide is just a
pie chart of Revenue distribution to um
the state the Charities and The
Operators and how that has changed over
the last um couple of
years the HHR Revenue distribution
obviously is if three quarters of the
revenue is going to the operator
obviously the pie chart is going to be
operator and so on the next chart is um
just the overall re it was requested
last year the overall re last meeting
the overall child gambling Revenue in
this state for FY 23 is that pie chart
so it's $15 million of Gaming revenue
I would also submit to you that based on
our reading the revenue is
accelerating also I would note that
based on our fiscal note for HHR the
current HHR revenue is more than twice
what we anticipated per machine when we
did our estimate for revenue for the HHR
machines we estimated I think yeah 125
per machine and I think was 1 12200 or
1500 machines yeah, 1500 machines
right now the machines are running
around
$270 per machine which puts them in line
with the facilities in Oxford and Twin
profitability I think Twin Rivers is
running around 290 and I think Oxford I
think is 240 so it's between those two
profitability
and the next slide is essentially a
indication of
the just the the speed of growth of
charitable gambling after HHR begins
think uh the next slide is a breakdown
of the charity Revenue over the last
four
years going to the the amount money
going to the the Charities obviously
it's increased as we've made steps to
increase vet limits increase facilities
increase obviously horse racing has a
that and the final slide is the state's
revenue for charitable gambling
obviously has increased we originally
had made an estimate that it would max
out around $12 million a year for the
state I think that's going to be
significantly lower than we anticipated
so um that is a lot of information in a
very short period of time um and so I I
truly appreciate you're saving your
questions till now and we'd be happy to
answer any questions you have and
obviously this is not an exhaustive
study this is very top level stuff we're
going to be dig on this I imagine Mr
chairman over the next year Point by
Point area by area and we're happy to do
so so thank
you okay
thank Mr chairman thank you very much
for the presentation early on in the
presentation during the Bingo section
the highly contested and uh bingo area
you mentioned it was a loss leader is it
a loss leader due to market dynamics or
is it state regulations leading to it
being a loss leader I I would say that
Bingo is just not that
popular yeah I think it's an age thing I
don't think teenagers are lying up for
Bingo or 20y olds you know say 21 year
olds but yeah
yeah ch got a question um I know when we
did the bill we wanted to try to protect
the the the Charities that have been
around for a while yeah and we had a
phase in uh split was different and it
was going to eventually become equal the
new Charities because there's two
Charities per it's also correct they
cannot open the doors unless there's two
Chari sponsoring that not correct so on
HHR there are facilities HHR talking
about HR yeah so um how we doing with
that is it been a problem to do that
split of the money
so so I can address that um it hasn't
been an issue yet we're still in the
period where we are grandfathering in
the existing Charities the Charities
that were there before HHR so they're
still getting uh a greater share of the
overall profits then new Charities that
are coming in are are are not getting an
equal share
um we are getting close to a place a
stabilization point where we've grown
the pi by two uh but we're not there yet
um and one thing that's actually
complicating it a little bit is that um
with the BET limits on uh games of
chance uh increasing as well that's
increased that number so HHR has even
further to catch up to sort of double
that number um
so we may get to a place here early in
24 where there is a slight reduction in
the amount that any individual charity
may get um because we haven't quite
quite doubled the pie we've come about
we're about probably at 1.7 1.8 now HHR
is still growing substantially but I'm
not sure if we're going to make up that
Gap completely by that time period okay
thank
you yes question of him Gina hi I don't
know if it's a question but I will say
with the previous legislation on HHR
they did the two Charities which we have
charity partners that benefit and I'm
very proud of it I was excited to get
too there was a little flaw in my
opinion in that legislation where it was
only for Charities that benefited in
20120 we closed down for 3 months in
2020 so I felt really bad that we had
some charity partners that couldn't
return for three months and I did not
want to as an operator my other side of
the Hat obviously I'm on boards as well
but as an operator I didn't feel right
about picking winners versus losers so
we opted to pair the same tier Charities
together the entire year so our
Charities actually make a little less
than they made before as we
expand but for us as an operator we
decided to make it fair have everybody
split everything in half especially
given that some of those Charities
didn't benefit for those three months so
they missed out I didn't want to miss
out
twice well and I would also like to
comment a little back it's a little
complicated on the pie chart for
HHR I know it looks like the operator
gets all that but they take on all the
expense you also have to make a deal
with the machine manufacturers the
machines cost maybe 50,000 a piece or
you do a lease agreement and you have to
pay the totalizer people as well but
those are like private agreements so
they're very hard to put on a pie chart
well the the one thing you said though
was
you made a decision to do something that
I thought we had in statute at the very
least in rules that said that we would
phase
in that so that I'm a little concerned
about about that that we we were going
to phase in um the the Legacy we call
them the Legacy Charities versus the new
Charities you made a decision to make it
equal from day one where are we with
that Mr chair let me uh see if I can try
to explain exp the how that works and
how operator may choose to proceed as as
um Gate City has um the the Charities
are given designations or either a tier
one or a tier two tier one were the the
grandfather Charities for lack of a
better term so if you are running a tier
one and a tier 2 charity tier one gets a
higher percentage of the overall profits
from games of chance in HHR right um
there is a mechanism because we couldn't
guarantee that there would always be a
tier one or T tier two that you can
operate with Charities of the same tier
at that point the charity allocation
gets split in half so if you could have
two tier ones two tier twos
um what gate city has done and and some
other operators have done as well to
make things um more evenly distributed
is uh run the same tier at the same time
which under the rules creates that 50/50
so that's really the operator's decision
um we have that mechanism in there to
protect the Charities if they if they so
choose to run one and two together but
they certainly have the right and
legally have the ability to operate the
same tier at the same time if they if
that's what they choose
okay thank you for that yes sir yeah I'm
G
to ask for maybe here a heck of a lot of
paper if you want or at least a access
okay maybe to a website or something we
can get can we have a full list of all
the Charities okay by operator how much
they're you know how much they're
getting and how much the expenses
are so that we can go over and kind of
just but by expenses do you mean the
expenses of the operator or the expenses
that the operator charges the charity
the the expenses that the charity is
paying that that's reducing that so we
know what the operator is charging the
charity we wouldn't
yeah yeah we would be able yeah we give
that to you okay no that would be very
helpful yeah I think I think the
committee would like to see those kind
of numbers um that's so where we're at
with the dollars the real dollars yeah
of
course
um Senator Senator oh thank you uh
excuse me Charlie with regards to the
breakage the the you know the more play
the greater the breakage does all of the
breakage go into
this fun to to for Char for problem
gambling because usually breakage is
split read the old days was always split
yeah there was a legislative change last
session where all of it goes into
problem gaming from so 100% of the
breakage goes for HHR for HHR yes for
sure So based on the play I don't know
what number you put in place but that
number is going to be exceeded
dramatically well yeah so when we meant
our estimate on breakage was based on
our estimate on revenue and historic
horse raising revenue has far exceeded
what we estimated so that's why there's
more money in breakage right it has not
kept at a restricted fund uh it's
restricted fund yeah it's it's go for
problem gambling and like I said it's
the money is exceeded what's in the fund
as approved by the the
budget okay thank
you
dick this is a question about licensing
and um and historic horse racing uh um I
understand that game operator employer
license is required in order to run
historic horse racing is there a an
additional lure or level of game
operator employer license that uh
qualifies uh enables a uh facility to
run historic horse racing and if if
there is or isn't uh is there any fee
associ C with that uh enhanced license
status or additional
license um thank you representative I'll
um I'll try to explain it as best I can
so that in order to apply for a historic
horse racing license you need to have a
game oper your employer license um and
there are suitability determinations
done at both levels um the way that um
the law or excuse me the rules read
right now the historic course tracing um
suitability review has many more um
requirements um that are put into the
into the rule terms of that
multi-jurisdictional um so the historic
course tracing review is very in depth
um and it's in addition to it
supplemental to the games of chance or
game operator employer um suitability
review so it is a separate application
it is a separate license there is no um
license fee uh for a historic course
tracing license um there is a uh
potential investigation fee um and we
have a right to be reimbursed up to I
believe 50,000
$50,000 the uh our experience on those
is they they come in you know much lower
than that usually between 5 and $110,000
U but that's the only fee associated
with the application for the historic
course tracing uh
license there's neither a license fee
for the license itself nor in some
jurisdictions you pay a license fee per
here okay Senator l so Charlie ex Mr
director so again could you kind of walk
through gaming right so what's the
handle what's ggr we're going to hear
all these as we go through this and
probably giving a base Foundation some
members would be helpful to
understanding how we get to the number
that we start breaking apart into
operators and that kind of thing so
maybe you can walk through that a little
bit to give a little primer for
people
mean um if you could rephrase the
question you want to know how the money
I put a dollar down right what does that
what does that represent how much of the
how much kind of walk through what that
dollar looks like or the handle I know
we have the
handle okay I think I I think I
understand your question hopefully I can
I can do it so let's uh let's say you go
and uh let's use sports betting although
that's not charitable gaming but that's
probably that's what I'm most conversent
with but you put $100 on the Pats uh
this weekend um we would call that the
handle um so that's the amount of money
actually bet um it would not be a very
good BET right now based on where the
Patriots are playing um so I'd advise
against but um
so for
us we would be happy so uh when that
$100 uh goes uh in um let's say you bet
uh ma Jones to third interception um and
you've won right so we're going to pay
those winnings out um ultimately what
we're looking at in terms of uh the
accounting procedure is the money that
comes into the house is the handle then
there are prizes paid that is the
greatest expense that comes out um what
the difference between the money that
comes comes into the house and the
amount that gets paid out in prizes is
usually called gross Gaming revenue or
Gaming revenue we have just to confuse
you guys you know there there's
different terminology that's given based
on different games but for the most
point part that's gross Gaming revenue
so as Charlie says that's the money in
the tail after after the day after the
prizes are paid um obviously operators
have expenses based on that um and they
have to pay whatever U Revenue share or
tax is associated with that they have to
pay the Charities out of that money um
and so that's the smaller pie that you
start slicing up in terms of taxes and
again that takes care of the operators's
overhead um and then ultimately then
they'll have a profit based on whatever
is left over at the end of that so
hopefully those are sort of the
different levels of accounting where
things get broken up if that Mak sense
sense question yeah I think you're about
to say what I'm about to say go ahead
can I we so we create
uh a glossery of terms that we can hand
out as well sort of a primer on
definitions we use all day every day but
certainly are not English to most people
so we can I can create that for the next
meeting and so if you can when we're
talking about it you'll know the right
verbage c l so we'll stick to well we
use just tle games again so in a given
night the the house will get a certain
amount of handle people have bought into
games and and do that they have their
winners and their losers so they have
all their winners they pay out those
winners and that comes off that handle
that is played that night so whatever
the money is that night and then from
that handle you have ggr the gross
Gaming revenue which is basically the
net of what they have left over um and
then from that the operators can do OD
so they can is it a straight split at
that point or is there additional fees
that come out before the split it
depends on the game as we've outlaid
here in terms of what's retained but
we'll use historic RAC racing it's the
cleanest at the whatever's left in the
drawer or the the box at the end of the
night if it's $100 they keep 75 and pay
their expenses and their employees 25
get sent to the other side of the house
and that's split two ways 16 to the
state eight to the charity
um that's the split on that that's the
literally one more one more so again so
relative to let's go the table games
because we have this rent issue which is
a specific T charge to our community
talk out yes um so again once we get the
ggr does rent come out off the top of
that and then deide it or is rent charge
how's that work rent is charged uh so
rent for games of chance is a flat fee
um that's contracted for before the game
date um so that is that is up to the
charity and the game the game operator
to negotiate um it does vary from room
to room um but that that's a flat rate
now the only thing that is they they
cannot go negative so a charity cannot
owe money at the end of the day so if
there if the rent was $500 but the
charity only made
$400 uh they can't lose that $100 the
worst they could do is get zeroed out
and in Operation game operators
ultimately will usually reduce rent if
they have a unlucky night or an unlucky
run um to make the Charities as whole as
possible so last question make sure I'm
clear on that so rent doesn't come off G
comes off the percentage the charity
gets and they subtract it from that
correct and the the folks um John and
Val work with confirm in each
Marketplace what a commercial reasonable
rent would be to confirm that is they
not being overcharge thank you wasn't
isn't there in statute a a maximum
though is it 750 or is it isn't there is
there a maximum there there there is no
maximum the what the statement in the
law and I'm paraphrasing somewhat is
that the only constraints are the fair
market rental value for the property for
any use so it's not specific to Gaming
use so for example if you could rent it
out for a wedding at $1,000 a night
theoretically you could charge $1,000 a
night for um for for gaming um I just
want to interject one other thing too
because we're talking about the
different levels of accounting here and
it's important for those who are not as
familiar with gaming are coming into
this a little bit newer that handle is
obviously always a very large number um
but in reality that is not the money
that walks into the facility so for you
know again taking a if you're sitting at
an HHR and you're betting you know
you're $100 you put $100 into the
machine you could sit there and win and
lose and win and lose and win and lose
you may be up $20 or down $20 at the end
of the day but if you were there for a
couple hours betting $2 every you know
couple seconds your handle number may be
astronomical and maybe $4,000 $5,000 in
reality you just had that $100 that went
back and forth over and over again so
it's just important to keep in mind when
we look at handle numbers obviously that
has a relation to ultimately what the
revenue is going to be but um it's
important to know like if we're talking
about hundreds of millions of dollars in
handle that doesn't necessarily mean
there's hundreds of Millions ions of
dollars in the facility it could be the
same dollar that moves along very you
know back and forth many times so
following up on Senator Lang's request I
think it'd be helpful to have take one
facility or make up a facility and do a
little chart that shows this much money
and where it goes that I think that
would be very helpful and then I want to
throw a little twist what about poker
because poker is handled a little bit
differently uh and a lot of lot of rooms
do have poker and then there's regular
poker and then there's tournaments so
can you just touch on on how that all
works that I was
making go ahead poker how's it how does
they have a work poker game with the
chips have value chips have no value
explain the difference in you go you're
GNA test
my well I I can address the general I
the the poker Works differently in that
the house takes a rake of it on the top
so they're not as opposed to um if you
go to the roulette table you know it the
house gets paid based on the outcome of
the game um in poker the the house takes
a rake uh at as part of the game for
hosting the game oh raake is just
they're taking a a they're taking a fee
essentially for running the game so it's
not related specifically to the outcome
you're not play if you're playing in
poker you're not playing against the
house they're just they're they're just
basically taking a hosting fee for
running the game for having the deal
when is that fee taken I go and I put
money on the table and they give me
chips I'm assuming yeah so is a certain
certain they get certain less number of
chips so when does that transaction
happen that that the rake happens right
the rake happens on the so you're you're
actually I'm not a poker expert but I
believe and I could maybe ask Mr goes to
help us out but I think that gets taken
out of the pot as the action takes place
correct that's right so everybody throws
their chips in and they pull over the
dealer pulls over the rake which is the
casino's portion of but what Al so but
what percentage is The Rake uh it's a
flat fee I believe per table so I don't
know the exact amount but it's not high
and it's it's every Casino across the
country does the exact same thing
okay but then but I I I know I know uh
representa delandro is a poker player so
I think he understands this too so thank
you for the compliment but it's to set
and it's different on the tournament
it's a flat percentage of you know if
you play a tournament for $100 is 20% I
believe for the so that's tournament
play tournament play yeah right but all
right yes thank you Mr chair um can you
go over the rent again I I'm kind of
confused about the fixed rate rent it's
a fixed rate rental fee going in and
there a percentage of the portion going
uh can we out after that we're mixing
apples and oranges here or well can we
also back up a little on the rent when
did we put rent in in in the statutes
was it always there because it used to
be the old days charal
gaming uh you know used to be in
somebody's in the basement of the church
and the the company would come and then
but then in the beginning all of the
Charities actually had a be there and
have role and even handling the money
and then then charl gaming and our state
evolved to a point I'm assuming
somewhere along the line we don't have
the Charities helping so that the
facility decided they were going to
charge rent is corre is that a correct
so is I understand it because it was
before my time dealing with charitable
gambling it was
2015 and the facilities which were
operating charitable gambling were
actually losing money and they need to
add rent as an additional profit Center
to allow the facilities to maintain
operations is how was explained to me so
that was that was the history of it
correct that was history that's how rent
was added to the law in 15 okay we get
to now get question to answer there'd be
a base rent plus a percentage of the
okay that's where I'm confused no I I
apologize I probably confused you it's
just the base rent so if you come in
it's you would sign a contract with a
game operator it would be let's just say
for $250 a night that's what you would
owe um so the way the cleanest way that
this would work is you'd make $1,000 as
a charity you'd have a contract for
250 so you would pay them their 250
you'd get a check for a th000 and you
net out
$750 so what is the 10% of the Charity's
portion um is returned to the the
operator as rent it
says which and it ranges from 5 to 50%
by room so uh on that slide I think what
that's meant to convey is that um on
average based on our
analysis Charities end up paying about
10% now that is not that's not how it's
charged okay so I guess the the best way
to say it is Charities still pay on a on
a a fixed rate and based on our analysis
of the the relation between that fixed
rate and how much money they actually
get it ends up being around 10% on
average if that makes
sense okay follow follow and you also
said they're not allowed to lose money
correct so that would be less rent or or
the same rent correct so if there if the
if the amount of money if the amount of
Revenue that the charity was going to
get from the gaming day exceed did their
agreed upon rent um they'd have to
reduce that rent to at least make make
it a break even for the charity okay
thank you so I had a new charity
approach me a couple of weeks ago that's
I not going to mention the name of the
facility that said they F they got their
first check the first that
electronically
sent uh but then they got a bill in the
mail for rent no one talked to him about
rent I I think we need to we need to get
our hand around rent here um as part of
this um I I I I told them I think
there's a cap on it I was wrong it
doesn't sound like there's a cap on the
rent and I I I think that's something
that we need to really address and I I
know it's one of our you know one of our
charges so but I think it would really
be helpful to have a a chart with an
example that we can you know one for
games a chance and one for HHR how the
money flows I know I know there's it's
totally different and then I think we
have an explanation now on on poker I
think we're okay
well well lucky S I had a question about
Lucky 7 too um so with with the Advent
of HHR is it is it uh to to have for the
terrible locations it used to be they
had to have Bingo running that day to do
Lucky
Sevens uh for my observation that wasn't
always followed but that's another
discussion
but is is Lucky Seven in the charal
locations dying because of HHR I would
imagine they are uh because I don't are
they still some of these facilities
still have
Bingo and we have strictly bingo halls
we know those still exist we know we
have other uh you know uh veterans
facilities other locations that have
Bingo um that that do sell Lucky 7 uh
but is Lucky Seven in the terrible
gaming locations is that a dying thing
so for the most part yes um there are
still some facilities that are not have
not have decided not to do HHR at this
time that still have Lucky Seven
machines in games of chance facilities
it says assuming that they have Bingo
because I thought the statute said that
unless the statute change then no longer
have to have Bingo um the law was
changed with regard to that and Mr chair
just to explain a little bit about I
think some of the rationale behind that
was um we were
getting um very limited bingo events
where maybe one or two members of uh
staff or people who are walking by uh
were being pulled into the room to run a
bingo game for a few minutes so that
they could keep Lucky Seven machines on
um so at the legislature decided to
divorce Lucky 7 from Bingo and allow
Lucky 7 to also be operated with games
of chance again because of HHR the
prevalence of that in games chance
facilities is definitely reduced uh but
it's not it's it's still it's still
present in some some locations okay
thank
you Lang and then so again just two
things I want to just go back and just
clarify some about rent so rent comes
out of the 35% that the charity gets but
on top of any other any other gaming
operator gaming operator's money they
get rent on top of that it just NE it
can NE never go negative is the only
thing that is correct with the
clarification that it is a it is a flat
rate fee it is not it is not related by
percentage to the 35% that they receive
it's a flat rate fee that comes out of
that 35 35% is less than the rent they
pay nothing for rent they pay they pay
the lowest number for rent get nothing
I'm thinking a a snowy Wednesday night
when nobody decides to go out and game
right and so they may have a flat fee um
but the 35% is is less than the rent so
therefore they would just get zero the
charity would get zero dollars for that
night's activity correct so again I I
think we bring this up again in next
meeting if you can prce a chart that
shows the flow the actual example of one
fac not real numbers one
facility this is and show the various
steps of how the money flows for both
helpful
right right it'd be helpful to see what
the range of rents are
and so one more fell so go back to Lucky
s our conversation now about Lucky Seven
so lucky s are now allowed in Social
Clubs BFW American Legions those kind of
places U moose clubs um
um how many LIC how many facilities are
those licensed by you as well do they
have to come in and apply for a license
and how many of those locations have we
seen an increase a reduction in those
locations uh that on
that's um I I'd have to look to see for
the actual number but it's probably
so well representative duet had his hand
up before and just go going back to
breakage real quick because I've been
kind of wondering I know the dedicated
fund is
150,000 um and looking at the trend
lines for uh Revenue right now obviously
breakage is going to be a bigger number
are you seeing an uptick in requests for
problem Gam issues are are you tracking
that is it something we need to correct
legislatively to make that dedicated
fund bigger because of that or if if
you're not seeing any change it just
curiosity so we have been in touch with
the um with the Council on um problem
gaming um who is a a private uh entity
that um has been associated with the
state for number of years uh they were
contracted with the state um uh most
recently in the last fiscal year um we
have not seen a significant increase
it's something that we've been looking
to see um there's been a pro probably a
slight increase in the number of calls
being received
um but it's not um it's it's it's
not escalating at the same level as the
amount of gaming is um so thus far um we
haven't seen a huge uptick in Rook quest
for
services follow yeah yeah so to to the
point of U the dedicated fund being said
of 150 is that adequate at present is it
something that you know how does the
director supp we address I mean candidly
it's it's not enough to do it well it
just isn't it should be a larger fund it
should either be zero or significantly
more it's just enough to not fix a
problem but cause one in the sense of if
you should hire staff there should be
dedicated folks looking at this there
should be dedicated research looking at
this um one of the difficulties is if
you don't look for a problem you don't
see the problem and so there are more
folks that probably have an issue that
are being addressed currently so be Paul
again sorry sorry Mr chair be clear
Lottery doesn't have staff that is
looking at specifics to problem gaming
we we deal with an outside vendor
correct so the the law created a council
on problem game
which we which is administratively tied
to us which has a specific meaning in
the law so I as you can imagine it would
be more than awkward if I was the head
of Council on problem gambling it would
make no sense so I'm fully in support of
it but certainly divested from
it okay represent BR had a question
thank you Mr chairman um for my own
information mostly but
um Lucky Seven decline is that because
of the
Kino um I know no I would it would
likely be that folks that had Lucky
Seven machines have now have historic
Forest racing machines because a lot of
the social clubs for had Lucky Sevens
for years and they made quite a bit of
money and then all of a sudden they got
the Kino and now they're taking out the
Lucky
Sevens um I I have you seen that you
could take a look and see do some
analysis on that frankly we haven't at
this point I think the decline obviously
is it's relatively slight and
anecdotally I would have to say there
were there were a few fairly large games
of chance facilities that had a
significant number of Lucky Seven
machines um what the one in Manchester
um that's that has um transferred to
Historic horse racing I think that would
have the most material impact on that
Lucky Seven number so anecdotally I
don't think we've seen that Kino is um
has has eaten into that those but um we
can we can do some further analysis on
on that and come back to you on it well
the interesting about Kino it's
different than than
U charal gaming is that a town has to
vote it in uh so not every town where
where are we with that is it about half
the towns or cities I know it's your
favorite topic no actually it's ironic I
was in Portsmouth last night oh you are
pitching there for the public hearing on
Kino uh the Portsmouth uh mayor and city
council we have 84 town nine cities and
one unincorporated Township that have
authorized
Kino um there are a number of towns and
cities that or not cities number of
towns and unincorporated townships where
there would be no lensey so we didn't
seek approval you know of some of the
places particularly at North Country um
and so there are a few cities like
conquer for example hasn't approved it
Keane hasn't approved it um Portsmouth
has yet to approve it you know knock on
wood they will next election um but
the vast majority of the state's
population is that lives in a place
where Kino or is bordering town that Keo
so my town of stratum I I got a finally
got somebody I'm not a former
constituent let's say called me say Pat
why we have Kino here and I said well
first step go talk to the three
restaurants that pour liquor in this
town and if if they want it then then
did talk to the selectman about getting
a warrant article but I don't think any
of the three restaurants really want it
so so why bother you know as as a
practical matter of the the bars and
taverns at cell Kino it's one in
five launch Keo and it's a decision by
the business owner whether they want or
not want it but some businesses fits
great in sports bar it does great right
um but you know if you sell if you're a
fine dining not going to happen so
Ames this is a question on historic
horse racing and the uh takeout or
commission which is in the statute at up
to
12% um and I've puzzled over that that
those words up to
12% and uh wondered what are the what
are the factors that uh key into a uh
less than 12% um takeout and uh and what
in fact are you seeing in terms of take
up um fundamentally that's a decision by
the operator and the floor mix of the
machines at any given time and it has
number of variables one is the player
base that you're deriving your revenue
from if there's no other choice so for
example say there was a HHR facility in
Pittsburgh there's nothing else around
you could have a lower prize payout but
if you're in a area where there's four
or five facilities around you you have
to have a competitive prize pound
because the players will know and they
will know immediately and so that's
going to be a point of a variable the
operator will want to use competitively
against the other rooms nearby and
that's a decision you know day in day
out the floor mix um we joke there are
some of our facilities that they never
saw a hand card they didn't like so they
keep moving machines around constantly
to get the right floor mix and so um
that's what that's that's it's very much
a business decision on the operator on a
daily weekly monthly
basis follow up go set it looks like
on so let's see we're we're talking
about take out from the handle yes and
the handle is everything bet do I have
that right no so we're talking take out
of the money left at the end of the
night
yeah no sorry we're yes we're talking
about Price p yes talking about handle
correct so in the example before where
there $2 $2 $2 yeah it's
the $2 time 10 times he did it is $20
and that's that's the that's the handle
and then the make out from it is up to
12% of that do I have that right you do
yes I'm sorry yes you do and and that
number is an incredibly important part
gambling so just that
um and this is why it's very difficult
to do an overview of everything because
the the accounting that we went through
before of you have the handle then you
have the prizes paid and then you have
the till and you start making divisions
out of that that is not how historic
horse racing operates historic hor
racing operates on a takeout at the top
so the house takes the money off of the
top and then it's paramutual wagering so
the all of the prize money then goes
into a pool that is then competed for
amongst the players so the accounting of
from our perspective for HHR is a little
bit flipped on its head where the money
gets taken off the top and then you
start talking about the prizes the prize
pool at that point in time yeah it's
um well I'll leave it at that I'm let
Senor alandro I think you G and then if
you think of it but if you use the per
perut cuds that $2 bet that you put in
off the top
comes 10 sets right off each dollar
correct which is uh correct all right
and then and then you get you get
returned on on your on your on your bet
based on the the calculation is based on
the amount of the body that's that's bet
but off the
top correct go correct and to uh
represent Ames earlier just uh question
about how much it actually comes in it's
a lot more than 12 it actually comes in
just slightly under 10 on average okay
so people should people should
understand that so is that is that under
10 consistent with other loc other
facilities make it too high then then
the payouts are going to be less and
then you
I looked at M sorry I looked at Main and
R Island last night and it's very
competitive with those okay I think BR
Island one of the rooms has a smaller
has a a lower payout but I think it's
because it's geographically uh
separated someone have a question over
okay well I was just going to say yeah
Nationwide it's somewhere between 8 and
12% and that's what operators have found
is the best return to get the customers
back right you take 15 20% you're not
not going to get the return the players
aren't going to have an entertaining
experience so that's really kind of
where the nation settled in some
jurisdictions Vegas Atlantic city where
it's highly competitive and I want more
time on device for my players that's
going to be my competitive Advantage
like um like you mentioned that's when
you see a little bit lower but they're
still not lower than about 7% yeah I
mean the provision regarding 12% was
actually put in as a consumer protection
at the time it was not meant to be uh it
was meant to say we won't go lower than
this because if you have a room up in
Berlin for example where has no
competition would be unfair to have
those players be have a lesser product
yeah then there's jurisdictions where
there is no cap you could hold 80% if
you want it but all the operators are
still on that 8 to 12% right
right sen representative am again I'm
sorry wa representative am yeah um
so there are slots that are not
paramutual much
more
um frequent in the United States and
there's historic horse racing which is
on a paramutual basis and so
um my understanding is sort built into
the slot
machine uh
machine
programming is essentially a takeout
because the the payack back is not
100% it's less every overall there's
going to be a loss to those who gamble
with slot machines and that's in the 8
to 12% range that you were talking about
correct slot machines HHR they have
other class to which are based on
lottery um math it's all in that 8 to
12% for if I may it's it's really a a
question of competition engaging the
market and what what you
can take out and and uh you won't be
hurt by it competitively and what you
can't cor it's just about getting the
players back right if I go in and I lose
too much money or I don't get enough
time playing I'm not entertained or I
never win then I'm not going to get
those players
um my plan at the moment is to go to
11:30 does others have puring things
before that or or do okay CU I think
there's still more questions but for
respecting everybody's time we'll keep
it to two hours for today um I do have a
question I'm looking at at the
commission the official commission
charge whether whether the state should
limit the number of charal gaming
locations right now there's no limit I
can come you know Senator Lang and I
could say we're going to we want to open
one of these places if we meet all the
characteristics of uh uh you know
background checks and all that we can
open one of these uh we don't have a we
don't have a restriction on the number U
unlik Kino we don't because I I I was
grilled on this when with my HHR bill
was well wanted we wanted we have a opt
in for the towns for historic racing I
was say well no this is just a form of
of gaming that that already exists in
these locations so but the question
comes in the future do do we want to
limit the number of these locations
that's the big issue to me to address uh
I know when we had our Casino bills in
the old days there was always one or two
then it was arguments why not
four right now we have like 12 is
it it's well it's 10 HHR facilities
operating currently and there are more
we come online
Okay um but with less owners right
there's owners that own m multiples
correct correct right right but how
about charitable gaming itself how many
how many charitable gaming 14 we're at
14 now yeah so we had a high water mark
of around 16 16 right so okay so this is
one of the big issues we got to we got
to address um and um and the problem for
me is we want more Charities involved so
the way to get more Charities involved
is to have more of these um but then as
we consolidate because there's some
consolidation going on and we're taking
two smaller ones and making one larger
one and but we're limiting we're
limiting it to two Charities where the
where the Charities are going to get an
astronomical amount because they're
bigger bigger facilities so we have to
have some kind of I think in our
discussions uh how do we how do we
control that um my goal in with HHR was
not to hurt any of the existing
Charities and what they were making and
I think we succeeded in that um but you
know going forward if we wind up having
consolidation and bigger facilities I
think we have to have we have to look at
what that looks like in terms of the
number of Charities that can participate
any given day uh because we're looking
at right now my understanding is that uh
for the bigger bigger Halls that we have
um for 10 days you can walk away with a
charity you can walk away with over
100,000 uh for basically doing nothing
and they love it uh and I don't blame
them um and it's it's a wonderful thing
for the Charities uh but it's really I
think we got to really this why I say
big picture because the the environment
is changing that we're you know the
whole complexion a lot of Outsiders now
coming in probably a lot more money
coming in building larger facilities and
um we don't have
any again all of our regulations and all
of our rules were based on smaller
facilities
uh that uh you know all did okay uh now
the world has changed and we got to I
think have to address that but one of my
thoughts was um and I know uh
representative Ames was very active when
we were looking at casino
casinos um you you chair the commission
looking at the regulations how we would
do that and that was that was at the
heart
of all of the other uh
uh gaming bills for Casino bills that
came and then then those bills stopped
because there was no interest
anymore um is it do we I'm just throwing
this out to the commission and the
Charlie you too um do we want to match
up what representative ames's report did
with what our regulations are today
because basically the facilities we have
are real casinos I mean with HHR they
are real casinos um I think I didn't
talk to you in advance about this but do
you think that would make some sense and
then
Charlie the
uh undertaking of that commission back
in
2014 or 13 something like that
um was
to identify
the reg regulatory structure that should
be in place in the event that the
legislature decided to go forward with a
large casino and it was um either in the
either a single large facility or maybe
two or possibly three but a very small
number so big
Casino uh the commission's charge was
not to opine on
the should or shouldn't but if you do it
this would be uh the best way to do it
at least in the Judgment of the
commission and that's what we
developed um and in the end put forward
uh separately from the commission a bill
and I sponsored that that called for a
large Casino maybe two I don't remember
um basically using the regulatory
structure and that came close but didn't
make it um so uh there's a lot of
material in there and the uh commission
was uh assisted in its work by a entity
that uh we contracted with after a
competitive bidding process uh White
Sands gaming something like that um and
they were very good I thought we all
thought actually and uh and so there's a
lot of material there that could be
looked at in connection with this but
bear in mind that
unless there was a recommendation to
consolidate what's out there already
which would be extremely difficult and
go to a um a large Casino um platform if
you will um a lot of
it is for large casinos a lot of the
work product there is for a large Casino
model and we're talking
about probably we're talking about um a
uh
a number of and that's part of our our
um
charge how big the number is a number of
relatively small gaming rooms um as I
understand it um and so there is that
that starting point do we want to look
at the big ones uh which means
consolidation because it really doesn't
a big one is going to swallow up every
Everything the small um probably I don't
know um yeah so it was the Massachusetts
model uh that we were looking at at that
time okay so but there are certain
principles in
that there are certain principles in
there whether it's a large Casino or
small Casino wouldn't you say I mean of
I I was just I'm thinking out loud here
that that possibly we could match that
up with what the regulations we have is
there something that we're missing that
we need to have
uh because I know I wish Senator dandre
was still here um um I know that's one
of his big things you know is is is the
regulations
proper now last term we had a joint
committee with the Senate where we tour
these the you were on it we tore a bunch
of these facilities and from our from
our standpoint things looked pretty good
you know we looked at we saw the cameras
we saw the the room The Counting
Room um and and all the other things
that are are going on um I'm just saying
is there a way that we could we could
take advantage of the work that you had
done to match it up with the regulations
that we have now is there something that
else that we need to do um and Lou I
said um I was s i was suggesting that
possibly we take the the report that was
done that was shared by commission that
was chaired by representative Ames and
match it up to our regulations now but
representative Ames feels that well that
was really for a large large Casino
wouldn't be relevant um but I thought
maybe there are certain aspects of that
that maybe we could learn from that's
all I think Abes represent Abes is
correct that was for LGE facility that's
what we looked at that's all that's all
the information we gathered but
certainly there are a few things that
that we could we could take uh would
help us here uh but indeed he's exactly
right that was for a large facility and
that's where we spent all of our time at
that at that point in time but it seems
to be we're we're growing into lar of
facilities here that was my point and I
think that's that's where the the
interface of of the Synergy takes place
because we have uh if if you look at the
television we have live casino here in
beer that offer
everything so so some of it could be
incorporate you know it's funny how the
market works you know if I was a big
Casino guy I look at at New Hampshire
and say well wait a minute this is wide
open there's no there's no limit on
number of casinos but am I going to be
competing with 14 other 15 other
locations uh maybe I'm not going to
build a bigger place here um but then
again it's wide open they could build a
bigger place if they wanted to take the
risk
so uh again we got plenty of time to
talk about these things and the
landscape has changed dramatically since
since our last right since our last
thank thank you so so I guess I'm think
talking about this consolidation thing
you you were commenting on and I think
we have a consolidation of ownership
right so we have some ownership
consolidation going on where have one
person or one business managing multiple
um versus the mom and pop we talked
about where we had one person managing
one facility um but to my knowledge we
haven't seen a consolidation where
someone's walked in and said we're going
to close these three down and focus on
this one that hasn't been um what's
going on within the state while while
they're buying multiple ones they're not
consolidating into a single giant
facility as far as I know how about n
what's that actually happened in Kean
there were two facilities that merged
into one but other than that you are
correct Senter right and how many do how
many do we have in nsha do we have three
three yes two eligible for HHR but now
correct I don't know what you know I
know what what we know about the plans
in naswa for the expansion down by the
mall well they're going to the Pres more
we don't no as as the regulator we have
not been approached with the plan okay
with so is a practical matter when it
comes to these we're the last stop on
the line you have to go to the town
first before you can visit before you
you have to go to town approval before
you can apply with us so right follow so
so so again I just want to clarify the
consolidation necessarily someone's
buying up 14 casinos going to turn into
one giant Casino in New Hampshire that's
not what's happening in the industry
right now as far as I know um and then
SEC secondly just to remind everybody we
currently have a moratorium right so out
of the 14 gaming licenses that's the
maximum number of HHR license we can
have in this state that expires 24 June
end of June 24 if I'm not mistaken where
I won at 24 that moratorium goes away
and again anybody who applied for a
gaming license would be eligible to add
the modifier of having HHR as well um so
there's currently a little bit of
constraint on the market um if you will
um and lastly I just remind what what
executive director uh McIntyre said was
that the one casino and in um Twin
Rivers 3500 gaming machines in one
facility we have roughly 1,600 spread
out amongst 10 facilities so there is
some Market space and Market Gap that's
happening again to deal with I'm
assuming travel plans right uh for
people yeah and most of the the
facilities are concentrated as you can
imagine On the Border um there's not a
lot of interest north of State conquered
U most of the facilities are within sort
of that magic 1H hour drive of the mass
border again but but again it's
unconstrained right now um we're talking
the future now not what's happening now
it it
could a big Casino could move in if they
wanted to with all the amenities if they
wanted to take the risk uh there's
nothing stopping them right where when
we talk used to talk about casinos it
was always limiting the number to to a
three but I I I like it the way it is
now myself I like it spread out the way
it is uh because we're helping Charities
throughout the throughout the state as
best we can um and but but it's up to us
as at the end product of this to address
that issue and we have to address what
do we want this to look like um least
Senor I I I if if I understand the world
of of G right now there are there are
three proposals for large facilities one
in Rochester at the Lilac ball one in
CER
right and there's a proposal before the
pleading Board of con for a rather large
facility and there's uh there's the
situation in nashaa where they would
like to move from one area to to the
shopping center which uh represents in
terms of square footage an enormous
growth uh growth pattern so I I I think
uh what's ha what I see happening here
and I
think this is the issue that that we all
have to be cognizant of is is the
enormous expansion of of an existing
venue and and now you've got to talk
talk about the the number of Charities
that are going to be there the amount of
money that's raised there uh when
historic horse racing comes there but
when you when you talk
about 100,000 square fet now that's not
the church
basement to the best of my knowledge and
then you know it isn't father father
Mone getting up and say team number two
will conduct the games on Tuesday night
those those days are going forever and
uh I I I think that's the thing we we
have to be cognizant of both the
Charities and in us as as Regulators
because if you get that kind of of
expansion it's going to require
certainly more surveillance on on on
part of of the entity the Lottery
Commission and there'll be more there'll
be more activity but that seems to be in
play as we speak and um we can't limit
advertising and marketing is a is a good
strategy but we we're seeing television
advertising that's advertising casinos
in New Hampshire uh I I think that's
something we have never seen before
we're adver advertising casinos in New
that gives people an opinion that we
have full range GBL uh you know in in
new G and I those are the things that we
should be cognizant of that our
committee should be should be looking at
you know thank you Mr this is a small
thing but and thinking about this last
night I don't think in our statutes we
do we do we have the term
Casino no it's it's one of the sticking
point so as you can imagine a number of
cities and towns have asked us to go
visit them because of this very topic
and I they asked me to Define casino and
I said it's not defined because it's not
in the in the law the law calls these
charitable Gaming facilities and so do I
you know we're in the executive branch
we don't get the right laws and makeup
words so no no it doesn't it there's a
law related to a casino or House of
ill-repute
being but other than that there's
nowhere in the laws they're defined
certainly historic horse racing you
didn't know that was part of your job
you didn't know that was part of your
job to regate my wife would suggest that
yeah
yeah well that that just dawn on me last
night
because most of these facilities are
calling themselves casinos now and
technically well is that it's not
violating a law I don't think but it's
but it's it's these facilities called
themselves casinos before they were HHR
for authorized right they did like I
mean you know you could call yourself a
beastro a cafe a restaurant I don't know
what it is it's just it's a gaming
facility and so well I think it's a
small thing but I think I think casinos
are here so I think I think the
legislature should at least Define it in
the statutes that's something that could
be in the report that we could suggest
to the legislature to do and also I
could suggest Mr chair I'm not in that
seat but if I can ask a question yeah if
we could also um re review a fee or a
cost of doing business to communities
that actually host these it would
certainly go a long way to those
communities of the number I have visited
and has been a bunch it has been number
one on their topic is
I expect increased services in my
community for this activity can we get
money from the state for to reimburse us
essentially for this and so like the
casino Bill representative Ames and I
worked on a number of years ago included
a essentially a mitigation fund for the
local community to be to host this
facility I think that makes a lot of
sense with care right I know it's in the
it's in our charge but I just want to
bring it up again okay I I agree with
that that's that's good because again
we're we're we're looking at everything
I you can't get away with not looking at
it all and say it's grown it's growing
what do we want it to look like that's a
good point when we used to do the casino
bills that was always a point of issue
the town you know was always Rockingham
Park was always the Rockingham Park was
the location it was the ideal location
they all had plans for for Rockingham
Park uh location that's gone now um but
I
remember there was there was provision
in there to to help the Sal them out
with the the traffic issues and
everything
else in in that legislation there were
Provisions for the for the for the codes
and for for the locals uh with regard to
sharing of revenues but also the law
enforcement the ability of the locals to
uh to take to out their share but also
to participate yeah and and these kinds
of things are going to are going to pop
up pop up in my opinion because of the
size of the entities I mean the entities
are growing in physical space and and I
think that's something that we have to
think about uh call look at when when
the public in the marketing sees Casino
they expect something there's an
expectation there and it isn't it isn't
the expectation for charitable gabing
it's an expectation for a casino and
that's how that's how they are now being
marketed as casinos that
requires a certain amount of of scrutiny
on the part of of the locals because the
locals are being called to service the
parking
lots uh and I know in Manchester that
has been a concern to our police force
what's happened in those in those
parking lots uh Abate Behavior Uh the
stealing of of vehicles at I so sure
that there's there's there's a certain
there's a certain amount of cost
associated with this that's got to be
absorbed by somebody because somebody's
going to pay
it so well this want to follow them Tim
um so yeah we took the tours we did ask
the question about security most of most
of the facilities had Security in inside
Security on their own um I can't recall
if that's in the statute that they had
to have security but most did have
security it's it's a regulatory
requirement for the historic coring
facilities to have a security plan that
we uh so we don't we don't dictate
exactly what that needs to be but they
need to demonstrate to us so his
facilities with HHR machines correct
okay we do not have a similar rule or
statute um with respect to games of
chance gener right right again this is
something that we should be addressing
as as we go along Tim than
so in simcast racing right again a
different form of gaming that goes on
but s cast racing that goes on um I know
the brook I'm not sure I should say
their name but they they pay C Brook a
fee for operating simoc cast are tune
about $225,000 a year the town gets for
allowing that activity so again maybe we
can bring the language in that looks
where that comes from and what that fee
looks like and maybe there's a place for
that kind of similar language in futral
isolation I mean yeah there's no
question there certainly regarding the
percentage that is
the
25% that can be looked at in terms of
who gets what I the budgeted amount for
the state we will well exceed that and
so there's more money as well as other
funds available the the profitability of
this is more than double what it was
anticipated to be and that's only going
to accelerate as facilities come online
in nashwa and otherwise there will
be significant sums of money generated
by this activity that could be sent to
the cities and towns follow yeah so
again I'm not saying where the
percentage comes from what happens or
anything else it just seems like we
already have a mechanism in law when it
comes to gaming for Revenue sharing with
communities we probably try to should
try to stay consistent in that model um
and maybe so we should probably look at
what that looks like and see how we can
do that I also think it should be relate
to the amount of activity in the city or
town so like Nash would get more than
Lebanon just because of the activ
involved and how much it would be
so again I just want to stay consistent
right so I'm not sure how that historic
how that uh Sim Gast racing model Works
to give to the municipality and what
what mechanism in law does
that it's not through us so that's them
them on their own are choosing to do
that I think so we'll check them thank
you you'll set there you have your light
on I was thought thought you were going
to no it's okay so um any other
questions from anyone I do have a
question represent Jan again yes so I
was just looking at the um the second to
last page the charity Revenue fouryear
comparison and
um you said Bingo is a lost leader so I
can see there's negative amounts for
each year there so I'm assuming the
revenue in each column there is that a
expenses yes
okay so the the Charities have they've
paid the
rent and then then they've also
subtracted whatever um wages they've
paid or other expenses they've incurred
and then this is the
net
okay thank
you okay any other questions for
today seeing them so let's let's uh talk
about the next meeting so the F oh is
another one oh representative Ames I
think
um there there is a question that needs
to be thought about maybe we should talk
about it next time it's up to you but uh
there is
$150,000 is $150 yeah ,000 allocated to
the work of this commission and the
question obvious question is how can we
best make use of that and uh you know
we're getting going and I in we're
starting into a time period we're
starting late cons because of various
things that have happened and here we
are uh we're going to run out of time in
the meantime if we're going to get
expert help if that's what the money is
going to be spent on we need to figure
that out and figure out what we want
that help to focus on um the one example
uh which I may be a poor example but
it's we talked about uh the bill that I
worked on years ago and the uh report of
that commission we could have uh we
could certainly use help I'm not going
to do it uh going
through um
that work product and identifying parts
of it that should be that might be
helpful to the work of this commission
you know that kind of thing well it's
it's funny you say that because that's
why that's where I was going with that
uh but it didn't seem like there was
that much excitement about doing it but
I was thinking of using an outsider to
to go through that but probably you know
we have to go out to bid I would imagine
to have somebody help us with that and
then match it up with our regulations
here um and um using a white sand kind
of white sand like it was white Sand's
kind of firm uh to do that um because
that that's the area I thought we would
need help on because none of us have the
time to do that or the expertise to do
that Senator because cedo charitable
gaming has grown across the country I
mean we think of it as as New Hampshire
but Delaware had to put charitable
gabing in they were the first state to
have casinos at the tracks and that was
a model that we used in the past but
they've been they've been forced to have
charitable gaming so charitable gaming
is there and we we ought to be able to
examine what it's what's happened around
around the country with regard to this
because it it's in my opinion
it's becoming very very large very large
and I'm sure that maybe 10 years from
now that that might occupy the greatest
portion of the of the activity by by the
lottery
commissions when when uh was there a bit
process to get get them in I don't know
how the state I would imagine there's
some kind of
a yeah so it's um Whit New Jersey and
there's a number of companies that do
this like Spectrum comes to mind they're
also out of New Jersey um there are a
number of Consultants that could do this
type of stuff
fundamentally the recommendations of the
wh Sands report we've tried to
incorporate into our operations because
if you're doing a if you're gambling in
the state you should have the comfort
that it's being regulated well and
regardless of what you call it we should
do it correctly and so we've tried to
incorporate that into our operations so
that I I can tell you with a certainty
approaching death and taxes we're
nowhere near as bad as it was in 15 when
we did this we did that report in terms
of regulations I mean obviously we can
make improvements but it's done much
much better now so so you know the
companies who this kind of work is what
I'm
hearing not companies but there are
companies that do this yes there are
Consultants that do um this and I mean I
certainly can generate a list pretty
quickly okay um for the next and if we
want to go to bid it's not that terribly
hard to do certainly we had number of
when I was on a study commission back in
2011 we had Consultants come in then and
I know a number of them is still there
Lou and I were on that one together
remember yeah
yeah
so certainly and there's a budget and
the budget I'm sorry I didn't address
this earlier but the the budget I
forwarded around was one administrative
Services required us to generate a
Budget prior to us meeting the the last
time so I had to submit something
Bradman Services which can be amended if
the body sees fit that that's just a a
placeholder essentially for a
budget yes uh what what I would
recommend and I've seen in other
jurisdictions is to get the list there's
probably two to four of these very
reputable um organizations have worked
for other states have them come in to
either the next meeting allocate 10
minutes each let them pitch and then
when we find the scope send that out and
let them come back with their
number is we could even arrange that
remotely if they wanted to pitch sort of
via tombs or zom uh Zoom or
teams Charlie I I'll I'll I'll reach out
to you we we'll coordinate okay thanks
thank you for that idea so uh and again
eventually we have to do an RFP of some
kind correct yeah and actually I oddly
might have the draft of the one we did
so um there's also I've talked to
Charlie about this before nickel G's
which is the National Council of
legislators from gaming states which
will provide us an incredible amount of
research I think it's like a $2,500
membership year annually for the state
or something like that but they'll open
up their all of their white papers to us
include responsible gaming
conversations um you know uh financials
for lot for gambling that's going on
across multiple States so I'd consider
joining an organization like that that
could provide us just simple white
papers that we can read and understand
without necessarily I as in addition to
whatever else we choose to do but okay
do you belong to any of those do you you
must get stuff you must get in fact
actually to senator's point I get asked
every year am I going to Nickel G's this
year and I always say no we're not
members and like we keep adding more to
the pile and so we're the number one
sports bet state in the country in terms
of per capita next number two sorry
you're number one we're three now damn
it so we're a very prevalent sports
betting uh state so we get asked
frequently to be on panels in nichel G's
and I have to say I'm sorry I'm not
going so yeah so just to be full
disclosure I have been on their panels
before I discuss discuss gaming gaming
legislation what New Hampshire's doing
how it's going um I find it to be an
incredibly useful tool to find out
what's going on in other states how
they're regulating things what their
financial models look like um there's
been some inredible again I've got two
or three of their events um it's an
incredible conversation so you suggest
and they charge a fee for disinformation
yeah well no if we're a member we would
get it as part what I'm saying so for a
simple flat fee we could probably get
access to lots of white papers and
conversation points that are available
only to the members of nickel G's
without having to necess probably not a
bad way to spend the
money it sounds like well so the
commission I'll pay for you to get that
certainly we belong to a number of
associations as well and sort of
get the benefits of this membership just
because of shared knowledge of our
industry yeah what kind of dudes we
talking about or I think it's like 2500
bucks a year five maybe five grand a
year at most okay all
right all right so let's let's talk
about the next meeting so I think I
think we continue on this thing I'll
talk to Charlie to see if we can um I'm
going to kind of got it you know from a
company I guess they prefer to have the
RFP in front of them before they come
and and and make a
presentation because we have to be kind
of specific as to what we're looking for
and then we can have a preliminary
invite them to our next meeting and they
can tell us who they are but they're not
going to probably they can say these are
the service we
offer um so um but that plus having I
think Charlie U um kind of a there a a
lot to do with the split of the money
and split of the money is something that
we need to really understand how that
works having that sample of how that
works for each of the CATE you know the
two major categories can I also
recommend that we present an analysis of
gaming across New England because it's
the most comparator area we do this in
terms of the the revenue split the size
of the area because it will all impact
on how we go forward um the market is
the market if you look back 20 years
casinos didn't exist essentially in New
England other than the tribes in concut
and now it's a much much more mature
market and so okay what we do going
forward should have an like we don't do
this in a bubble New England is a very
small area and so I was going to suggest
we do that as well okay okay that's
great and then don't forget the uh ahead
just concur in that I think that's very
important and uh I think it's important
that it be done in a way
that can relate
Massachusetts
slots facility to char Gaming facilities
here with HHR and the different ways in
which we um require the revenue that's
produced is distributed compared to and
then there's the uh licensing fee which
in Massachusetts is multiple thousands
um you know for the slots it's maybe
25,000 and then the big one is much
the it's million so uh wi and
Springfield was $85 million license fee
and plain Ridge was 25 million license
fee 25 and they pay every year a $600
license fee per machine yeah so so that
would be great uh really important and
also to that end I did um make a point
of printing out the uh tracker study for
the American gaming Association which
tracks Revenue across the country by
jurisdiction so I have a copy for
everybody I didn't want to pass it out
because Senator Lang looked at me like I
had three heads when I brought a stack
of paperwork and I was afraid of getting
shot so um I have that as well if you
want to grab a copy it goes by
jurisdiction by jurisdiction why don't
we why don't we hold the next meeting
you can hand okay all right I'll hold it
then okay last thing part of the next
minute yeah RSA 284 colon 23 is where
that Municipal language comes from it is
okay so I'll work with Charlie we'll
finalize all the things for the agenda
that Charlie will be doing uh and we'll
make a decision whether we want to bring
these companies in yeah
yeah so um so when so let's work
backwards we have to have our work done
by November 1st of
20124 that's 12 months um I I I don't
think meeting once a month is
enough
uh every other week may be a little too
much I'm I'm thinking about maybe every
third week uh what's going to happen
though once we hit June the legislators
around the table are going to start
worrying about running for office
again uh and but we do have
until you know November 1st plus we have
to have some time to write a report so
so
um I was thinking of starting
with um every third week um I'm willing
to do every other week uh but I'm just
looking for everybody's sense of of that
I um Mr chairman the third week would be
November 7th and that's election day
yeah doesn't necessar have to be a
Tuesday either okay and then the fourth
week is the
14th no well I I was thinking the week
of the sixth
um I guess it would be better to have a
standard day that we do this on uh I
know it's election day that day so the
legislators have to be cover Bo You Know
um
right so yeah right now we're at a
session and but which brings us to let's
talk about the room for a
minute
um let's talk about this we're using
this room right now when the senate in
session uh is the middle of the week is
a problem um I mean Mondays and
Fridays is that a problem or do we want
to meet at Lottery do you have a you
room
right well the house is starting to meet
this right yeah so it have to be Monday
or Monday or
Friday
um is it easier to get this
room on a Monday
issue right so if this was a if this was
a house if this was a
house commission they would say go go
find a space
outside um so I've I've always worked
with um you know permer Revenue whoever
we could meet there um easier for you
per speak in minutes too um but um but
until we're in session that's not an
issue
[Music]
so
right okay so but for next
meeting can we do it on the sixth but
start a little bit later ex there's a
hearing that I have to be at
9:30 uh to testify on on um something
um um maybe uh 10:00 or 10:00 on Monday
the 6th can everybody make that on the
six
yeah
yeah that
okay and to and
U Tim can you help me out to see if I
don't know who here regulates the rooms
can you help me with that oh Sonia okay
we'll talk afterwards well we'll firm
that up all right and we we'll get the
agenda out ahead of time um assume
assume it's in this room but may that
may change and then we we can further
continue to talk about the scheduling
how we want to do it going forward after
yeah all right all
right so is there anything
else for our next meeting that members
would want to at least touch
on
right yeah yeah
right okay thank
you our access to research if you want
to so Kelly has all the addresses so if
I gave her the agenda she'll she can ma
out to everybody okay
okay all right great all right um I
think we're set until uh the 6th and uh
we'll move forward from there
remember we're we're coming up with a
road map for the future here that's what
we're going to do so doesn't mean that
that that's law that means we're making
recommendations a road map for the
legislature to to use and guide there's
still going to have to be bills for any
anything we come up with a change that's
going to come out of this it's up to the
legislature we don't tell the legislator
we give him suggestions of what Char
gaming should look like it's really up
to the legislature to uh to move act on
adjourned
think